j'accueille maintenant bambou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
bon bon bon soir donc il parlait ça
n'est pas dernier du vendée globe
contrat - seule fois
romane bohringer kamel axelle laffont
voilà c'est plus en plus de filles sur
ce plateau devient très sympa alors
serge gainsbourg a eu trois baies dans
sa vie bardot birkin est bon en ce qui
vous concerne c'est lui qui a inventé le
b puisque c'est un surnom qui vous qui
vous a donné votre vrai nom c'est
caroline elisabeth von paulus et quand
vous rendre compte très serge rencontré
serge il vous arrivait d'aller fumer de
l'opium chez un vieux chinois vous dis
donc tiré sur le bambou ça s'appelle et
donc vous dit où tu vas je vais tirer
sur le bambou bas donc il vous appelez
bon pour elle est simple alors votre
père était légionnaire les généralement
qui a rencontré votre mère au vietnam
votre mère c'est madame comme on dit qui
descend d'une famille aristocrate de
pékin massacrés par mao et donc ils
immigrent votre perle légionnaires
allemand et votre mère descendante de
cette famille aristocrate immigrants
france mais se séparent assez rapidement
très rapidement alors arrivé en france
votre mère se retrouve dans un camp de
réfugiés vietnamiens dans le lot soit
vous êtes né des voix là je cuisine sur
le nez
mesdames messieurs et donc votre merde
se retrouve avec six enfants à élever
pour trouver la dass bout de l'âge de 6
mois à 6 mois jusqu'à 13 ans alors
évidement vous retrouver dans une
famille ça arrive on trouvait dans une
famille pas très pas très cool comme
dans toutes les familles je crois qu'on
s'est un peu cause elle quoi vous êtes
une fois j'ai eu le même cadeau que le
chien pour noël intialement à martinez
et un bout de bois avec des lanières
cloud
le chien avait exactement la même chose
en 13 ans j'ai ce cadeau c'est déjà pas
mal
c'est bien benjamin cadeau vous êtes en
sécurité quand vous êtes petit vous
essayez d'ouvrir les vingt neuf ans la
vie vous intéressait déjà plus à cet
âge-là je pensais que je mettais bourré
de monde je savais pas ce que je suis
comme ça il y avait le même problème
vous demandiez vous aviez atterri quoi
donc effectivement c'est ça qui vous a
amené plus tard vers la verra drogue
vous dites je ne voulais pas vivre
jusqu'à 30 ans en fait sauter une ligne
de vie qui fait le tour du poignet
l'onglet pas à wayne je suis mal barré
vous avez un ancêtre qu'avec jusqu'à
s'entend donc sans un crime on l'obtient
c'est comme ça le sursis va être là on
l'attend ce n'est encore pour un moment
là voilà prévenus
ouais vous faire une raison la wii alors
effectivement à l'âge de 13 ans l'idée
de la mort est toujours assez présente
chez vous et vous allez avoue des fonds
c'est quoi un jour en sortant du lycée
vous allez chez eux chez un dealer en
fait du baby sitting groupe id fix non
oui je volais des mobylettes enfin je
ferai beaucoup de choses
à l'époque j'étais active à une personne
ne m'a amené à la drogue j'y suis allé
tout seul au moins vous avez le mérite
d'accuser personne d'autre c'est grand
et on sait ce qu'on fait et c'est
tellement facile de mettre la faute sur
quelqu'un d'autre alors que nous alors
quand vous rencontrez serge gainsbourg
j'ai 19 ans vous traîner un peu c'est là
qu'on s'est connus vous traîner un peu
avec l'épaule matin les femmes du
cannabis est avant donc vous traîner un
peu avec l'époque du palace et c'est eux
qui vous ont fait découvrir la musique
de gainsbourg parce que vous étiez pas à
brancher du tout et vous flashez sur
l'homme à la tête de chou que vous
préférez à melody nelson
un mois c'est ce qu'il a fait de mieux à
haut niveau
lyrics toute musique tout enfin tout un
concept album comme ça c'est c'est
parfait cette intersection
alors vous le rencontrer à l'elysée
matignon en droit aujourd'hui disparus
et alors il ya un titre qui vient vous
dire monsieur gainsbourg ordonne que
vous alliez à sa table vous dites quoi
ce vieux con qu'il aille se faire [__]
quoi bah oui des arbres je voulais vous
donner des ordres
déjà ils arrivent vers vous il vous dit
le vieux con il vient à ta table espèce
de boudin c'est sympa comme annoncé en
matière le vieux convient bien
c'est vraiment très beau alors
effectivement à l'époque il était assez
malheureux parce que déjà une venait de
le quitter il était blessé il cherchait
quelqu'un qui comprenne pourquoi yat il
voulait quelqu'un qui le comprennent
sans avoir besoin de parler ce que je
comprends c'est bien toujours mieux les
couples on n'est pas obligé de parler
asiatiques sont très forts plein dedans
et c'est vrai à l'époque si vous n'aviez
pas été aussi défoncé est-ce que vous
l'auriez supporter dans l'état où ils
étaient parce que vous c'est pas
gainsbourg j'ai connu ce qu'un
gainsbarre oui mais je me souviens qu'à
14 heures
je le voyais à la télé je me disais si
je te veux enfin si je voulais un papa
je voudrais pas comme lui et j'ai été
exaucé haut de l'année
désespérant et c'est drôle parce que lui
est tombé sur des lettres et où il voit
mon petit papam souche était incapable
d'écrire serge donc dans mais laisse
marquer toujours multi patat il me fait
froid on a une haine papa c'est vrai que
buvaient et moi je prenais des
substances qui m'aident à supporter
l'insupportable je ne m'en vante pas
mais je l'assumé
de toute façon lui au courant de tout
donc il ya aucun problème et c'est vrai
que ça peut-être facilité certaines
choses qui
qui était assez lourde à porter alors
quand il pleurait des fois gainsbourg
était malheureux il pleurait mais quand
vous approchez lui que vous lui disiez
ne pleure pas il dit ne t'inquiète pas
ses larmes de crocodile manipulateur
directeur oui mais en même temps c'était
sincère puis en même temps il avait un
recul sur lui même on sait s'en vont
aller faut pas la quitter
c'est vrai il se trouvait moche tout le
monde le sait c'est vrai qu'à un moment
il vous laisse crever un oeil qu'on
l'appelle serge le borgne et pour dire
comme ça au moins on saura poursuivre en
tout cas je suis moche voulait justifier
sa sale gueule c'est vrai ça je savais
et un jour il vous demande d'arrêter la
dope vraiment quoi de décrocher parce
que il voulait avoir un enfant vous avez
déjà eu un avant vous aviez perdu voilà
et là vous êtes dire on sait même pas
qui c'est sa personne sont été aperçu
dans une chance à ne même pas vous est
donc là vous vous dites je vais arrêter
et puis on va faire qu'on va faire
proprement comme vous l'avez quand même
temps avant lui deux ans aurait deux en
avant
effectivement vous avant qu'on voyait
des femmes enceintes ça vous ça vous
choqué parce que vous disiez tellement
de malheureux sur la terre dieu sait si
vous aviez été malheureusement votre vie
mais il ya tellement de malheureux sur
la terre c'est pas la peine d'en faire
un de plus je comprenais est convié des
femmes osez vous aviez envie donner des
coups de pieds dans le ventre et très
violent mais quand j'ai vu ma soeur
aînée en fait c'était comprenais pas
mais pourquoi ils font des câlins qui
sont malheureux compact parents et qui
demande qu'une chose d'être adoptés un
peu l'amour est dans une grossesse
difficile en plus donc mal gré mal gré
la décrochent une partie sous perfusion
dans la cause des contractions
regardez moi ouais mieux vous devez
sortir à six mois ils sont six à huit
mois quelque chose c'est ça alors serge
n'ont plus supporté pas trop les femmes
enceintes un salut oui je dirais tu
reviens avec le paquet cadeau cadeaux
oui est ce qui a été très étonnant c'est
qu'il a été odieux avec moi tant que ça
se voyait pas et dès que j'ai commencé à
avoir un petit noir il
et et d'un amour c'était de la folie
c'était tout le contraire de ce qu'ils
m'avaient dit et moi j'étais prêt à
partir à lui ramené de cadeaux et avait
pas de problème est la non il ne fait
plus partie ouais alors lui il voulait
une fille on sait pas pourquoi parce
qu'il avait déjà eu quand même la vie au
moins charlotte puis ses enfants d'un
projet d'un premier mariage
c'est bizarre
ouais ben oui une fille une petite
chinoise et donc les gars on va prêter
très content de vue évidemment pas comme
je l'aï déjà dit c'est lui qui m'a donné
envie de faire des enfants
les trois de plus alors quand l'enfant
né la presse parce qu'ils étaient bons
gars pour les médias c'était son truc
donc vous êtes en page 3 de france soir
l'entrée en première page
et parce que la presse voulait
absolument attendait un enfant bizarre
quoi parce que vous étiez déjà qu il
était alcoolo penser que je vais faire à
montsoult donc quand tu vois que saab
était normal et tout mettre en troisième
page de françois remetter il a été
consterné en dix ans n'est plus tant
qu'il ya des bonnes nouvelles sont pas
contents on se retrouve en troisième
page est effréné accroc en or et la une
c'est ça mais c'est vrai qu'ils
manipulent et beaucoup les médias par
exemple la barbe de trois jours c'était
toujours un truc était un petit peu
entretenues et dandy pas ce critère
c'est beaucoup de boulot
ouais d'avoir une part de 3 ans et
savoir quel jour il faut se raser pas
quel jour et c'était très dandy il sort
des billets de 500 francs qui les bus
brûlé à 7 sur 7 il l'avait il avait
réfléchi s'était pas ce contenu de sa
main avancé il se demandait qu'est ce
qui te fait faire ils me demandaient tu
crois que je peux le faire et si je vais
en taule souviendra world qui
m'apportera désormais mieux si donc il
savait tout ça mais c'est vrai qu'il a
pleuré quand il n'a pas eu la une de
match parce qu'il pleurait toujours pour
voir la une de match il n'avait jamais
eu un jour il vous dit
je lui les gens de match au téléphone si
tu si tu te montres sur la une avec le
bébé et nous la donne vous vouliez le
protéger ce bébé est malgré tout la
effet il a eu sa une de match est très
attendrissant oui qu'est-ce que par de
jouer avec le même temps ils
comprenaient pas qui avait pas un retour
immédiat quoi est-ce que lui ce n'est
complètement et c'était très très
calculée de fou mais c'est vrai qu'avec
le talent qu'il avait la une de match
c'est pas grand chose
alors quand ils allaient à la télé un
peu pété un peu bourré comme ça avoue
langueux liège et comment j'étais en
sortant de l'émission à vous comme vous
étiez vous l'aimiez vous lui disiez mais
pas terrible
oui mais il me disait ah tu une [__]
tu veux me démolir le moral et tout est
à la fin chez pas quoi faire donc
parce qu'après ce que la gueule pendant
une semaine les intéressements sympa et
donc après je les enregistrais qui se
voit a voulu montrer les cassettes vidéo
est ce que je pouvais pas dire que
c'était bien qu il était complètement
et puis c'était gainsbarre et puis il
fallait qu'il en finisse avec ça qu'ils
ont la page donc je voulais qu'il soit
et qui les reculs et là il a été choqué
et là j'ai vu est arrivé
et
[Musique]
la séance d'enregistrement c est
terrible il vous faut et en plus mon
retour en studio j'avais des paroles là
juste au moment même où je me suis dit
comment je vais faire il m'a insultée
parce que j'étais à côté de la plaque et
où on a dû le faire sortir du studio
ah oui parce que ça laisse terminer
content parce qu'il avait fait de lui
enfant de l'amour quoi ça sert
et après il est revenue et tout s'est
bien passé
vous avez dit un truc pas je suis pas si
c'est très beau en tous les cas c'est
très touchant
vous êtes donc beaucoup souffert comme
on l'a vu pendant votre pendant votre
enfance et vous dit lulu a exorcisé mais
ressentiment et j'ai pardonné jardin se
faisait pardonner au reste du monde pour
qu'ils vous aviez envers qui vous aviez
une vraie violence au passé j'avais
peut-être car comme vous et réconcilier
avec le monde
la nuit j'ai sauvé une vie en donnant la
vie
voilà alors lui voulait mourir en
dormant un gainsbourg c'était son rêve
il avait peur de la mort il disait
toujours le mieux c'est que les dieux
l'ont exaucé il est mort en dormant
alors après sa mort ben évidement vous
c'est difficile pour vous hein
vous avez manqué de retomber dans la
came à ce moment là non ouais j'ai dû
baisser parce que les médias on nous en
avait complètement oublié real estate
sais c'est que j'ai pas voulu jouer le
jeu non plus donc je responsable de ça
mais c'est vrai que lui est tombé sur
certains livres et il m'a dit mais c'est
toi tu es une erreur la deuxième parce
que apparemment papa il a aimé que jen
est chez lui et tu crois pas ça qu'est
ce que tu fous là
donc là vous avez été malade une espèce
de maladie un peu de psycho somatiques
vous êtes devenu assez parano et c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de critiques à ce
moment là on vous reprocher d'en avoir
voulu combler de serge d'être publique
serge ses biens comme c'est bien sûr un
atout je sais bien mais à l'époque je
dis les gens besoin vous ont reproché sa
ils vivent le servent
on a sorti faire que ça ouais je n'ai
rien fait non plus pour rester dans le
milieu je dirai pas ce qu'un jour vous
êtes invité à dîner par françoise hardy
et jacques dutronc qui sont le la
marraine et le parrain de lulu et vous y
allez pas mais sans prévenir quoi si
vous n'êtes pas très social bombes ou
des raisons très personnelles pour ne
plus parler d'accord ah oui c'est pas
juste pour payer avec quoi
oui et à partir de là vous reprenez
confiance c'est à dire que comme
d'habitude quand on touche le fond
remonte à propos d'un moment vous
reprenez confiance et vous décidez
d'être une super maman
[Musique]
là vous décidez selon le désir de serge
de lui faire apprendre les échecs parce
que serge étant d'origine russe serge
m'a fait confiance et m'a toujours dit
que je serai une bonne moment sais pas
si c'est une bonne maman mais j'essaie
de faire de mon mieux et puis pâques
pour lui mais le look bien évidemment
pas simple
ouais vous avez fait apprendre les
échecs le piano il a fait combien
d'années de il vient de passer son
examen de moyens de après cdf supérieur
et d'affiner voilà c'est bien nous déjà
vous avez rempli là je vais remplir la
mission maman déjà été dur parce que l
école est beau c'est pas trop la vraie
école et la petite fille attention les
jarres is vous écouter ensemble de
chansons de gainsbourg tous les deux non
c'est très on est très pudique elle le
fait de son côté à part une fois on
était en inde et c'était il ya trois ans
et je crois qu'il avait 13 ans né il ya
deux ans donc il était en train
d'écouter de lire c'est la première fois
sur le moins d'élire les enfin les unes
lyrics de son père et de son cou une
pause des écouteurs une lime attend
maman papa c'est un génie il voit mal et
dire que oui alors on parlait d'argent
tout à l'heure lui va hériter quand il
aura 18 ans d'un quart des droits
d'auteur puisqu'à quatre enfants qui ont
droit ça donc un quart des droits
d'auteur serge lama fait de testament
donc vous finalement vous avez ce que
vous donnez melanie stryder travaillez
pas vous avez vous finalement vous avez
ce que ce qui vous est versé par
l'administrateur c'était en famille le
bal par mois pour élever l'enfant et
pour tous pour l'éducation d'enfants
vous êtes a peur quand tu vas avoir 18
ans qui va voir tout ce pognon qui pète
un peu les plans le plus main parce que
je l'emmène chez l'habitant en asie en
afrique et il voit une autre réalité
il a réagi comment la commémoration de
la mort de son père la balle à ses c'est
pas terrible froid qui allait retomber
et et c'était comme si son père était
mort la veille d'un seul coup il est
voyage de comprendre à cavan 15 ans
voilà donc ce qui ce qui comprenait pas
avant d'un seul coup ça lui il est tombé
sur la tête quoi ouais alors la mort de
serge a été très médiatisée c'est normal
c'est une façon de lui rendre hommage à
son talent puis à sa personnalité
alors vous vous avez préféré honorer la
date de naissance de serge c'est quand
même déjà une idée plus joyeuse en tous
les cas et vous sortez un vous chanter
un duo avec lulu qui s'appelle ne dit
rien c'est une chanson de gainsbourg man